wir müssen über einen neuen look dauern
sprechen das wollen wir alle nicht aber
es gibt ein neues papier dass unser
kollege bild meinung chef philippe
piatti mitgebracht hat ein brisantes
papier aus der bundesregierung wo kommt
sie her und warum kommt das jetzt ja
hallo k
das ist ein papier des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums das in den
vergangenen tagen an die länder gespielt
wurde
und zwar geht es ganz konkret um die
vorbereitung der nächsten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz an angst am
dienstag so ist es da trifft sich die
bundeskanzlerin mit den
ministerpräsidenten der länder und zur
vorbereitung hat das bmg von jens spahn
dieses papier erarbeitet hier sind gar
nicht mal so viele seiten aber da steckt
wirklich ordentlich sprengstoff drin
denn das ist die strategie der
bundesregierung für den herbst und
winter für die sogenannte vierte welle
sprengstoff sagst du da müssen wir rein
schauen deswegen in genau dieses papier
philipp das tun wir hier am großen
screen und schauen mal in diese seiten
rein in die entscheidenden sätze ein so
einschneidender locker und wie in der
zweiten und dritten welle wird aller
voraussicht nach nicht mehr notwendig
sein schreibt da das
bundesgesundheitsministerium vorne im
papier klingt erstmal erleichtert
allerdings wollen wir das wort lockdown
raushaben aus sämtlichen papier und
jetzt steht hier als pseudo entwarnung
es kommt nicht mehr ganz so schlimm wie
in diesem jahr und im vergangenen jahr
war philipp ich verstehe das ehrlich
gesagt so dass ein locker und durchaus
vorstellbar ist da steht der wird nun
nicht mehr ganz so einschneidend sein ja
wen wundert's wir haben auch eine
impfquote von über 50 prozent
eigentlich hätte da stehen sollen ein
log down ist völlig ausgeschlossen und
nicht ist durchaus möglich aber eben
nicht ganz so einschneidend wieder vor
ja schauen wir noch mal drauf philipp du
hast das gesagt also dass das wort
lockdown überhaupt noch vorkommt in
diesen papieren das ist eigentlich der
fehler wir wollen das raus haben aus
diesen papieren das wort locker und
schauen wir weiter in dem papier was
wichtig ist nämlich diese passage da
steht daher sollte unabhängig von der
inzidenz ab anfang mitte september 20 21
die teilnahme an bestimmten
veranstaltungen in ganz deutschland und
nur unter einhaltung der 3g
regel möglich sein 3g regel das müssen
wir bisschen erklären wird hier in
klammern erklärt geimpft gewesen
getestet philipp also die teilnahme an
diesen veranstaltungen nur noch möglich
wenn man geimpft genesen getestet es
richtig für berliner ist das zum
beispiel keine neuerung wenn wir hier in
die in gastronomie gehen müssen wir
einen impf genesen und oder test
nachweis vorlegen
aber das ist ein ganz vielen
bundesländern eben nicht der fall in
baden württemberg in bayern in
niedersachsen
da gibt es die incidents niedrig ist
keine nachweispflicht da kann man
einfach als freier bürger in ein
restaurant gehen ohne sich ausweisen
sind also für die ist es eine
verschärfung das was da dienstag
beschlossen werden soll und das
entscheidende ganz schnell noch der
blick auf diese seite insbesondere für
ungeimpfte personen können somit
abhängig von der impfquote der inzidenz
und der hospitalisierung rate ab
bestimmten grenzwerten erneut
weitergehende einschränkungen
beschlossen werden eine weitergehende
einschränkungen notwendig werden für
bestimmte gruppen nämlich für ungeimpfte
person dass hier was hinter mir hier zu
sehen ist diese passage philipp das ist
nichts weniger als die vorbereitung des
lok downs für ungeimpfte richtig und die
haben schon den richtigen pr slogan
dafür ausgewählt das steht da das sind
die letzten worte zweig statt drei gehen
man kann also nur noch ins restaurant
oder zur veranstaltung wenn man geimpft
oder genesen ist aber es reicht nicht
mehr nur getestet zu sein
das heißt ungeimpfte com selbst mit
einem negativen testergebnis nicht mehr
ins restaurant das sind massive
einschränkungen die die bundesregierung
so auch nie verkündet hatte im gegenteil
die bundesregierung hat er mal gesagt
wenn alle angebot hatten dann fallen
alle einschränkungen für alle bürger weg
jetzt wird verschärft und zwar für
ungeimpfte das den ausschluss der
teilnahme nicht geimpfte personen
veranstaltungen in der gastronomie ganz
konkret kinder unter zwölf kann nicht
geimpft werden was bedeutet das es ist
auch hier mal wieder überhaupt nicht
explizit angesprochen was ist mit den
kindern richtig kinder fallen erstmal
runter es ist also nicht klar ob es
sonderregelung für kinder geben wird das
kann natürlich sein dass das bei der mpk
wieder rein verhandelt wird es gab ja
auch immer wieder mal sonderregelung für
kinder dass sie vom kontakt
beschränkungen
ausgenommen sind aber das steht auch in
dem papier drin wir haben gerade kinder
inklusive über 30 millionen bundesbürger
ohne vollständige im schriftenstand
jetzt wären über 30 millionen bürger für
die inzidenz ein bisschen ansteigt nicht
in der lage ins restaurant zu gehen für
diverse aus genau das müssen wir ganz
klar sagen dass dieses zweig stadt 3g
was so formuliert ist was so harmlos
klingt und irgendwie nach handynetz und
so weiter dahinter verbirgt sich eben
der lockdown für ungeimpfte wir sind
bild und wir liefern dir deine news auf
youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren